you know the minority of sport what has
been a
a great tournament you know the majority
are
very proud of the players you know for
what they've done how they've lifted the
country sport has
you know the power you know to really
unite and it's
i think it's so important that we don't
just focus on
the minority you know this has done a
lot to bring people together
i've had a lot of racism over the years
and it's it's vile it's horrible and it
shouldn't be
but i think what this has done is is
going to galvanize
most people you know to support those
players because we we need equality you
know racist abuse
should never be you know in sport in our
communities and
you know those players you know you see
the the notes now left for for rashford
and the other boys it's
it's just amazing how people have just
said no you know
racism won't be tolerated and we'll back
you because we believe
in what you're doing and the amazing
things and the lift that you've given
the country
yeah indeed and i wonder if we might
just turn back to union just for a
second of course you played for england
won the world cup you also prayed for
the british and irish
lions which i'm sure was it was a
highlight of your career
what do you think the chances are in
nine days time that the lions have gone
against uh
against the spring box it's gonna be a
bruising encounter
oh it is and we saw that last night when
um when the lions played against south
africa a
it didn't seem like an a team to me it
was a very tough team and
unfortunately the lions lost but i think
that's just what the lions needed they
needed a tough game
because going out to south africa you
know it's going to be bruising you know
it's going to be physical and we saw
that last
night the confrontation was unbelievable
the lions will know that they've got to
do a lot better
aerially as well because we lost a lot
of ball um
but that's all part of the challenge and
that's what makes the line so special
four teams coming together you know
working together to play
you know the champions of the world in
south africa it's going to be difficult
but i believe the lions have got a
fantastic chance we've seen
alwyn jones has made a remarkable
recovery he's going to be flying out
there um
you know his leadership you know the way
he plays
he's going to be invaluable to the lions
and you know i can't wait to see the
games because i think it's going to be a
great test series yeah alan winjord's
coming back fantastic yeah just pop my
shoulder out straight back into
professional sport
three weeks later very very final and
very very quick question strictly
between you and me jason which do you
prefer junior league
i've been spoiled that i've played in
both codes absolutely
both games and i will always talk only
about both